Having figured this out, of course, Bob and Carol are both very, very happy--
not because they've actually solve their problem but now they know at least they can collaborate.
They've basically double their chances, so if any one of them finds a bit algorithm for their problem,
they will know they have a good polynomial time algorithm for both of their problems.
Alice also arrives to the meeting, and of course, Alice is very excited
to hear about their discovery that Bob and Carol have made.
Alice, of course, is hoping that maybe she can also find a connection of her problem
to Bob and Carol's problem or at least that they can help her find
a good algorithm for her problem by brainstorming.
Alice explains her problem using the graph terminology as well, so Alice's problem
as you will remember is to find a set of vertices so that all of the edges are covered in a network here.
For example if you take these three, then each edge has at least one endpoint
in those set of green vertices here.
The input for Alice's problem is again a graph with n vertices and the output is the smallest
set of vertices such that all edges are covered, and of course, you know what I mean by covered.
By covered I mean that each edge has at least one n point in the set of vertices.
Then we should give that problem a name to refer to it such as Bob was working on clique
and Carol was working on independent set.
We have Alice working on her problem, and since she is using the vertices to cover the edges,
we'll call her problem vertex cover.